What's a must-have superpower for
an undersea, water-breathing king?
The power to fly through the air with
teeny tiny wings on his feet, of course!
Namor's mutant power of flight is one
of his most recognized comics abilities,
and it appears his MCU debut will put it on full
display, complete with those trademark wings on
his ankles. Throughout the new trailer for "Black
Panther: Wakanda Forever," we see instances where
Namor is either levitating or flying around
in combat. The question of whether his wings
are a part of his flying power is a point of
debate in the comics. Some fans believe the
wings simply help him steer and maneuver, while
some other source of power, possibly telekinesis,
is thought to lift him. The fact that he is seen
levitating would point toward this being the case.
An interesting thing to note about Namor's
flight: Namor was most likely the first superhero
to ever fly in a comic book, with his flying
powers predating those of Shazam and Superman,
the latter of whom originally just made giant
leaps as opposed to soaring through the skies.
With that in mind, it's only fitting
that Namor will get to exercise those
ankle wings on his cinematic debut. However,
this is only the beginning of his powerset.
While flying around is cool and all,
it's going to take someone with both
speed and strength to compete with Marvel's
Black Panther, no matter who may be donning
the famous moniker following T'Challa's
tragic death. As we've seen in comics and
"Wakanda Forever" clips, Namor is more
than competent in both of these arenas,
possessing raw abilities that allow him
to stand toe-to-toe with even the Hulk.
"That can't be good."
Namor is a powerhouse when it comes to durability
and super-strength, and these abilities increase
exponentially when he is in the water, meaning
that even if one finds Namor tough to beat on
the surface, a quick dip in the ocean will make
him even tougher. While Namor's primary mutant
power is generally considered flight, it's his
strength, endurance, and unrelenting stubbornness
that will make him seem unstoppable even to
the forces of Wakanda. Though his water-fueled
strength is quite similar to another ocean-loving
superhero from the DC Universe, it's worth noting
that Namor is actually the original aquatic
superhero, predating Aquaman by two years.
Out of all the abilities that Namor has in
the comics, it's his telepathic abilities and
intelligence that prove most commanding. If Namor
weren't powerful enough on his own, his ability to
command sea life and the Talocans, with nothing
but his mind might be his most imposing power.
But can Namor speak to fish? The answer is
complicated. While he does have a telepathic
connection with sea life, it's more of an
influence over them that allows him to get
creatures to do what he wants them to do. This
is as opposed to the way that Aquaman generally
"communicates" with sea life in a more verbal
manner. For instance, those whales swimming in
the "Wakanda Forever" clips alongside the people
of Talocan? Namor is basically mind-controlling
them into joining the fight. Which is something
he can also do with other elements of the ocean.
Namor has the ability to manipulate
water and the weather around him,
in a similar way to Storm of the X-Men. We see
brief scenes of this power in action during
the "Wakanda Forever" trailer where the Talocan
leader appears to have flooded Wakanda itself.
It's a moment reminiscent of the comics,
where Namor did just that. This wasn't the
first time Namor attacked a human city in such
a manner, either, as 1941's "Human Torch" issue
5 saw him flood New York City to devastating
effect, an event that still lives in infamy.
Believe it or not, Namor was the first
"entity" to ever successfully invade
Wakanda in the comics, though he was
defeated by T'Challa and the Avengers,
and things eventually got sorted
out between everyone. However,
when it comes to Marvel's Cinematic Universe,
we will have to wait and see if Wakanda and
Talocan will ever make amends because
this is a pretty devastating attack.